you're not defined by
make money you're defined by everything
you do every day that nobody pays you to
do you do it because that's who you are
that's what you stand for that's what
will never be taken away from you
it's your quality your integrity and the
things you actually care about and you
do them whether it's convenient or not
whether anybody thanks you or not you do
them because that's who you are it's
feeding your children it's educating
whoever is in your life and being
educated by them it's everything for
which there is no money and money would
trivialize what we're talking about and
for me this non cash economy is
something that needs to be supported and
learned and recognized valued because
it's the only real value the other
economy that we're in the middle of of
course collapses ostentatiously every
three years like some giant disgusting
dying dragon and that is propped up all
over again and keeps not functioning
seriously not functioning meanwhile the
world continues because of the non-cash
economy because every one of us who
needs a break there's someone we know
who bails us out who keeps us going
through a difficult time who says okay
you can live upstairs
the only reason any of us are live is
because of that economy
that economy that's been there actually
when we deeply needed and of course
those moments of crisis
are the power moments in our life right
I mean when I'm doing a production and
if the production doesn't go into deep
crisis I start to worry it's going to be
a rather trivial production it's when
the production goes into deep crisis you
say okay we're on to something this is
going to be something worth doing
because we don't know what to do next
and we genuinely have to ask ourselves
some very deep questions and come up
with answers we didn't have before and
that's where the breakthrough is there
are in many traditions ways in which you
practice giving so after a while you can
start being very very very good at
giving because if you have no practice
it's hurts and the more practice you
have it doesn't hurt every time but just
to say I do believe the arts were
invented as this practice in giving and
practice in sharing practice in
simultaneous perception as in cubism
understanding there are several points
of view present simultaneously
recognizing what a dynamic in the room
is rather than top-down hierarchical
thinking beginning to understand how a
dynamic moves and in this case what
we're talking about in the 21st century
now that artists are making movies
musicians are painting everybody's doing
something that's not their art form
thank God
creating radically shared spaces so if I
may just go to the next step Rob
mentioned it I just want to mention to
you
I am founding at UCLA University of
California Los Angeles a new Institute
called the boethius initiative and I
just want to describe to you a little
bit of what I'm hoping the next stage
for education is but also how this works
in public life because it's now time for
universities to have serious roles in
public life once again because if we
leave truth-telling to the politicians
and to the legislators that will be a
problem